round 11 of the 2017 US Chess  Championships will be one to remember  reigning queen not see by kids he came  into the day determined to win but young  Jennifer you upset those plans by  defeating her a third champion in this  event to finish the tournament in style  that left the door open for Sabina  freezer who won a brilliant attacking  game against a / prover could giving an  emotional and happy subpoena our first  title as US Women's Champion there are  two grandmasters left standing as Wesley  sole and Alison honest chick battle it  out to see who will be named king of  chess in the United States the fight for  the crown starts right now